hi I'm Sean Bean I'm doing a wired or to
complete interview have I got to answer
this who is sure being married to I'm
married to ashley moore are actually
been now and she's my wife and she's a
wonderful woman and I'm very happy with
it
who does Sean Bean look like I used to
look like
Ian Glen I was in games and we were
always competing for parts when we were
younger when we just left her are
mystical who does Sean Bean support well
I've got three children I also support
Scheffel United football team in the UK
the blades just chuck it by holding it
what she'll be movies doesn't short be
dying
oh god I that's a hard question the
first film I made was a film called
stormy Monday well one of the first in
dare and I didn't die in that I nearly
died but I didn't the Martian I didn't
die in that
there's not many do I actually survived
it I said the old arrestor die which is
why I'm second in the dying League after
Christopher Lee after see if I can bump
it up a bit
what edge is Sean Bean my birthday's in
about two weeks to be 60th what school
did Sean Bean go to my first school was
a school called hansworth
junior schools not far from where we
used to live then I went to Athelstan
School which is just a little bit
further on until I was 12 and then I
went to a place called Brook school till
I was 16 I left at 16 what has shown
been naruse narrated I guess that I did
a thing called Yorkshire seasons in the
Yorkshire wild and I was all about
nature Natural History I've done quite a
few Natural History narration
and aerated I think all the elderscrolls
oh yeah did civilization yeah because
I've been in Boromir and I've been
Boromir in Lord of the Rings and The
Game of Thrones we tend to get sent
things that like old world mysteries
which you know I find quite interested
so they're quite a pleasure to actually
read what does show me think of Game of
Thrones
he's brilliant I mean I don't think any
of us expected to the abbot is such a
phenomenal influence on people's lives
you know you find politicians caught in
lines like winter is coming and this man
trying to use it for their own advantage
which is rather pathetic and it's quite
funny
comical really it was good for all of us
because he's intelligent and its wealth
planned out as wealth or his imaginative
and surreal and shocking and I'm very
proud to have been involved from the
beginning but just the beginning alright
stuck yeah sorry right
Oh Ned Stark now vice Ned Stark so
honorable I think he's because of his
lineage his heritage and his family his
father's before him his father his
grandfather I think they had a code of
honor which they which has gone on for
hundreds if not thousands of years he
was one of the very few men or women in
Game of Thrones that really had anything
that you could call honor or or fairness
or you know it was firm his firm with
his children with his with his people
but it was also very fair and very
charitable and respectful of of those
around him even the people he commanded
yeah why doesn't it's dark yell veil off
it's because Arya and I hold that bale
or would save him look after and keep
her keep her well you know keep her
alive
why his nets dark sword so big you know
that's why Shiva
he suffocates he's just like big swords
you know I think he said I want really
pics you're gonna when I get old dad how
did Ned Stark know winter was coming
when we first started Game of Thrones
use autumn and it was already start to
get a bit cold at that time so you know
by some we finished it was winter Sun I
knew he was there it's gonna get a bit
cold that year and then I've it was a
line in in the game of Thrones I fell me
unbelievable in it I've just said that
so really they're copy off me and
because I knew winter was coming
what does Ned Stark whispered before he
dies it was just something to myself
obviously
song game I've been gangam style that
was there or anything no I wasn't it was
a little prayer there sometimes do
myself and I sometimes say because I
wanted it to be something I didn't want
to just be like I'm holding something
young wait good luck you know because
that don't mean anything I think he
changes things so I thought I I thought
that I would do something that actually
meant something to me
it was a yeah you know plea for help in
some way
so that it actually didn't make sense to
me and it felt right for me and and it
was true why Ned Stark died he was a
good man and he was getting in the way
of things it was he wasn't corruptible
he wasn't he couldn't join in this
little nest of vipers that he'd become
embroiled with this a bit like someone
who was tortured or hose they want to
keep him alive but unless he agrees with
them and unless he confesses that what
he has done in the past is wrong then
they have to get to do away with him
like Thomas Moore in England in the
medieval times when they wanted him to
renounce his faith but he wouldn't they
tried everything but a
he stood fast by what he believed in and
they killed it fine ed Stark is the best
he could be the best because he's is the
only one with a moral compass the only
one who award you you you'll be able to
trust and to be able to rely on and ask
for advice and counsel I think he
probably is the best know in that way
yeah he's the best man did that stark
love Jon Snow yeah I think I think he
did yeah yeah it was difficult
relationship because of you know reasons
that have been already explained now but
he tried to treat him as he did all his
children and I think he he loved him is
one of his children why Ned Stark never
told Kaitlyn nothing Caitlyn had an
inkling of what gone on she noticed
there was a different relationship
between me and John maybe it was an
unspoken thing but I always had a
feeling that she she sensed something
wasn't quite true and you could say that
you know one of Ned's that's his
Achilles heel because you know he wasn't
loyal in that sense to his wife was it
so did Ned Stark know about White
Walkers I think he knew he knew of them
in knew there was something there yeah
because he was wary of things in that
area in that direction not part of the
world admitted because he didn't want to
alarm
he's his people and his family but I
think he knew there was something not
quite right over there and they'd been
there a long long time White Walkers so
I don't think maybe something was passed
on to his family and even if he didn't
make a fuss about it or mention it and I
still think he was aware of them does
Sean Bean have it's active I've got to I
could spin you off one is a Scheffel
United sets of waves
he says hundred percent blade which is
it played Nate name for the Scheffel
United I lied I'm very proud of that
and I've also got Lord of the Rings
Tatsu it's only about that big it's in
elvish in it means nine which is how
many there were in in the The Fellowship
of the Ring there were nine of us so we
all we all had that dawn and I had it
done here actually in New York it was
for the premiere of Lord of the Rings
and I went out with Orlando Bloom and a
large award and I was the last one to
have it and they kind of come on your
last one you've got a core of it don't
and I so we went out and we we saw
abandoned then we came home went to bed
next morning was September the 11th it
was a kind of bittersweet moment that's
a that 9 the following morning yeah
that's where I heard that Donen but he's
good you know how he's we've all got a
him so it's like a bonding thing in
quite crowded I want too why did Sean
Bean change his name I thought it might
be a bit Katia which it it must turned
out to be but I don't if it's for the
riders cuz everybody called me seen
being now or Sean born I just guess it
was a little bit fanciful where you know
I just left drama school I thought
catchy name and that was it really
and so on are Sean Bean and Viggo
Mortensen friends yes yes I got very
well with Viggo and he's an interesting
character he's a you know quite wacky
and slightly out there you know which
makes him very curious and very
interesting to me what I like about him
is that he's an actor and we all know
that but he's also a photographer a very
good photographer an artist and it's a
designer how many episodes did Sean Bean
play in Game of Thrones
haha I think I was in nine yeah I wasn't
in the 10th for obvious reasons you know
Thank You internet for googling me